This morning, my toddlers requested some corn flakes for breakfast,
but I don't usually keep those in the house,
so I just decided to make them.
I combined some cornmeal,
corn flour, and a tablespoon of coconut sugar with some water
until it was batter like consistency,
then line my baking tray with some Parchment paper.
Before pouring my mixture onto it,
I made sure to spread it as thin as I could.
Thinner you get this batter,
the crispier your corn flakes will turn out.
And I popped it in the oven for about 15 minutes
before pulling it back out and breaking up my pieces.
At this point,
it's still very soft,
so it's easy to rip everything apart
and get it into the shape and the size that you want.
I was done ripping all of them up.
I popped it back in the oven for about 50 minutes to an hour
at a very low temperature.
Once they were all cooled down and crispy,
I poured my toddlers some cereal into their bowls.
Today was a day that they wanted milk with their cereal,
so I poured some milk on top, and their breakfast was done.
I've been on a real cornflake kick lately,
so this is very exciting for them.